now the round between Gary lineker and
the BBC could be resolved as early as
today Sky News understands that there
could be a statement this morning
following a weekend of disruption to the
BBC's football schedule
olinica did not appear on Match of the
day over the weekend the BBC was forced
to ax much of its weekend football
coverage as a number of other presenters
announced that they also would not
appear in solidarity with Clinica
meanwhile The Rao left the BBC's
chairman Richard Sharp fighting for his
future after Rishi sunak declined to
offer him his backing
Richard Sharp was appointed by
government before my time before I was
prime minister with regard to his
appointment it's right that that's done
independently rigorously that process
happened before I was prime minister had
nothing to do with me and at the time
was conducted with all the way that it
should have been now that that process
is being reviewed but the independent
appointments commissioner has appointed
a leading Barrister I believe to review
that process right that we let that
continue